welcome to this video playing I got me
on I get me home from Columbia yeah not
really in good blitz shape here but
let's see me I can get something going
yang getting an aggressive game here
with them with this two lights defense
where I'm currently to Collins down but
it's an aggressive aggressive opening
and like always have some compensation
I'm going to try it to play quickly here
not shooting for the absolute best moves
but just try to get compensation him
quickly um rupee six would have been
interesting and probably preferable but
anyway let's let's stick to the game
plan of being aggressive and not use too
much time yeah this I mean I opened up
the F file or when g3 looks really risky
inviting me to go Queen e8 h 5 h 3 and
so on I really cannot believe that this
is even play on jus three I mean this is
a very greedy kind of play that he did
he just took two pawns the first one
then the second one on c6 I think it's
really risky okay not going to think
about it for too long
Queenie 8 age five
me you can argue about move orders but
it is definitely the right kind of idea
against against this this plane okay so
Queen to h4 is what he's saying
essentially that this is going to save
them okay i think i just take this and
now think about it maybeee for 495 this
and the screen h4 is a nuisance so let's
block the fourth-ranked and think about
the details later
hmm
yeah well I can go chief I've but Queen
g4 King each one hmm i have this with a
tempo it's it's very neat 95 with temple
King h1 ok is going there ok i can go
Roxy idea for an additional I mean this
is really really g5 is also also cute
spoiled a little bit spoiled here for
choice
but it looks like there should be a
direct win for sure I mean there are
many things that probably win but I'm
not sure that I'm seeing the the most
convincing one yet yeah okay come on
let's do this I mean it wins I think was
just thinking there should be some kind
of made or something but this wins the
bishop at least all my pieces are
protected and I don't really see any any
any great move that he can do yes those
checks on d4 c3 of it they don't lead
anywhere I came so 195 first actually
fatigue here he might have a five so
maybe should i do this first yeah I
think it makes some sense play this
first so that 'if I've is some is some
prevented I'm just taking it next move
yeah for Nyjah form
it's got H form to try to continue but
and maybe I should go Bishop c8 actually
Queen our queen h6 also was interesting
for Bishop a 6 yeah this is what I
should have done would have been really
strong ever been really strong
it's also pretty good
my Queen takes Knight g4
i don't know i mean if i get the pawn up
to f3 this nose resign more than more
than problematic I don't really know the
precise opening here it looks very risky
computer just wants to take on f3 now I
have a strong compensation but it's not
a clear it's not clear or anything it's
just just as strong but yeah Queenie 80
some some move yeah I don't know
something something like that is
interesting I mean after this it gets
really problematic check very difficult
if possible to play I always have
compensation he's putting out some moves
as well g-form
so like this g one yep I tentative and
it it's difficult I don't get a look
easily here to age 60 i was there he's
got g4 I can win I can win time on the
Queen somehow this this computer gives a
draw funny enough which is possible I
mean if we think about this kind of
thing I'm threatening here and this it's
very difficult out I have this this
initiative but it's not clear if it is
leading to anything more than some some
kind of equilibrium the computer is
giving it as equal funny enough here
like it's two pawns down but equal I'm
just I'm just putting out some moves and
here here's his 11 way to to draw that
interesting huh yeah tough game but the
way it's the way it went it was it was I
don't think it's defendable hear anyone
around here Queenie fight for stronger a
95 for stronger now he could have played
each form
just want to briefly check yeah queen
age 69 would have been good with this
idea but I saw this sausage to latest
would have been better even yeah
interesting game hope you liked it
thanks for watching